[Music]
Dave you're gonna go on tinder all right
well the way we start is we build our
profiles okay I work with the animals
I rescue animal I am an animal dentist I
am an animal dentist can I does that
mine are yours that's yours
Denise Denise Denise the gunner
look there she looks great she's 97 well
she says something some of that Kip you
watch she's 67 miles away uh-huh what's
our range what range that we put in here
we put continental United States six
miles away six miles away make this
laughing all right all right
hello hello call up the car call
everyone come around our way Franco's
gonna die tell ya he's got it
Stephanie she's 20 Stephanie I can't I'm
you but not me
I'm that's two I'd be curious if she
responds yes to you though if she does
then she's 20 but sure for her age she's
20 that's that creepy I'm messing my
staff 20 creepy or it's this whole thing
creepy well I'm gonna say no to
Stephanie I promise no one under what
age 27 been seven what about Sarah
though she's 23 looking beautiful do it
yeah I forgot what I was doing and I
started Yesi 19th on yours don't do that
well you know now that you've done it
what's done is done I always
how do i I didn't mention my sexual
prowess in the you have put I will be
crying right and apology right but
eventually it will happen I'm holding
the phone and you can see my wedding
ring nice job a whole job buddy boy
about Sandy no booty calls thanks why
don't you say et I might change your
mind once you see what I'm packing am I
really doing that no don't say package
say I don't like booty calls either
right so we're good alright hey Cynthia
should I cook you a complimentary should
we complement her oh yeah you get
complements if you don't like
compliments um I think you're really
cute there you go that's nice how come I
didn't think of that
I used to say I used to say your face
seems asymmetrical but things might work
out eventually and that never the second
half of the sentence ruined it there no
the first half is also well
our show a piece of wood I will put that
away if I were you just gets us arrested
immediately
I have never more felt like a murderer
on the prowl than I do like this is this
doesn't feel good being in this van guy
hug I was gonna ask if you disliked that
feeling heartily yes well no there's
part of me that feels it almost feels
like a second skin it feels very natural
you